injections vaccinations
svetelina giorgiova is getting ready for
the day
i expect 30 vaccinations today
it's different every day
it depends on the people
30 shots that's not much people here are
skeptical hardly anyone comes to the
vaccination centers so zvettelina and
her colleague chavdar are hitting the
road
we need more people to get vaccinated
bulgaria has the lowest vaccination rate
in the eu
we need much more to achieve the
threshold of at least 70 percent
it's nowhere near that in vratsa a small
rural city in the poorest region of the
country where about 30 percent have had
the jab and that is considered a lot the
national average is currently about 25
percent
svetelina and shavdar have been on the
road for months to change that they went
to various towns and villages but hardly
any people were willing to get
vaccinated now they are trying something
else a lot of people come to this
supermarket
javdar is full of hope
new discounts begin today so hopefully
more people will come and get vaccinated
sales in the supermarket are attracting
customers but the vaccination van is
less attractive
i'm worried it's not been sufficiently
tested it's still in process
compared to other vaccines for example
against tuberculosis that last a
lifetime this is only for six months
[Music]
i've seen videos that say people who get
vaccinated get some kind of a chip
inserted
false information like this is annoying
to those who got vaccinated
i don't get it
so many people have died
why don't they take matters into their
own hands and get vaccinated
svetelina and shaftar know the wild
theory circulating among anti-vaxxers
they try to correctly inform the
skeptics
i've tried to convince them
i also have close friends
who didn't trust the vaccine
who lost relatives
and regretted not listening to me
finally after more than an hour the
first patients begin to show up
vaccination
to change the overall vaccination rate
though the unvaccinated need to come
some anti-vaxxers eventually end up here
fighting for every breath at the local
hospital in vratsa
three doctors care for about 40 covet
patients
even among medical staff only half got
the jab that means just a few can work
on the covet ward
peter karemchiev who is in charge of the
hospital tries to explain what he
himself struggles to understand
maybe it's connected to the historical
and behavioral nuances of bulgarians
[Music]
they find it hard to trust anyone
[Music]
team maintain that the government should
increase local vaccination drives but
there's not enough healthcare staff they
say
hundreds work in western europe for
better pay and better
prospects we don't feel valued because
despite all the work we put in people
refuse to get vaccinated for some reason
they wanted to inoculate 30 people today
in the end
it was less than half that
some of the doses will be disposed of no
longer valid
they will be back out tomorrow morning
again though they say it's increasingly
hard for them to stay motivated